muy bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
la entrevista de france 24 en esta
oportunidad nos acompaña medical door
ella es experta en estudio sobre guerra
paz y seguridad además es profesora de
gobernanza global en el london school of
economics con ella vamos a analizar la
situación que se vive en afganistán tras
20 años de guerra y de intervención de
eeuu que finalizaron con el retorno de
los talibanes al poder y lo vamos a
hacer bajo la luz de varios conceptos e
ideas que ella ha desarrollado a lo
largo de su enorme trayectoria y que son
de muchísima utilidad para abordar
hechos de la actualidad mary calders en
khyber y matt for medical door muchas
gracias por su presencia en la
entrevista de france 24 hace ya varios
años usted sacudía el tablero académico
al señalar el fin de las guerras viejas
del siglo 20 y la aparición de las
nuevas guerras podría usted resumir esta
idea para nuestra audiencia y contarnos
cómo analiza bajo este marco la guerra
en afganistán y también los lineamientos
de la denominada guerra contra el
terrorismo que comenzó a eeuu tras los
ataques del 9/11
creo que tendemos a pensar en la guerra
como lo que yo llamo antigua guerra las
antiguas guerras son guerras con un
contexto muy arraigado entre dos bandos
normalmente estados normalmente soldados
uniformados cada bando intenta ganar el
encuentro decisivo es la batalla
las nuevas guerras son muy diferentes la
libra en diferentes grupos de personas
pero lo más importante es que son más
bien una empresa mutua o una condición
social
en las nuevas guerras los diferentes
bandos evitan la batalla no ganan por
ganar o perder solo ganan por la
violencia o la amenaza de violencia
y entonces pueden ganar económicamente
en la guerra contra el terrorismo se
gana dinero a través de los contratistas
de seguridad privada o de las empresas
que producen drones y tecnología o se
puede ganar dinero en afganistán a
través del contrabando de drogas el
secuestro de la toma de rehenes
güey
y también es una forma de movilizar
ideologías extremas el ideal de una
ideología contra el otro contra el
enemigo
entonces las ideologías étnicas y
sectarias y religiosas son muy típicas
de las nuevas guerras
y me gustan las antiguas guerras que
tenían principio y fin pero que a menudo
eran muy muy destructivas
las nuevas guerras parecen ser eternas
ahora tenemos el término de guerras
eternas en cierta forma estas son una
forma social de organizar la sociedad
mediante la violencia
mary usted tiene un enfoque humanitario
de los conflictos algo clave en su
perspectiva sobre las guerras es la
necesidad de ayudar a las personas en
ese sentido como le resuenan las
palabras del presidente joe biden cuando
días atrás dijo y voy a citarlo nuestra
misión en afganistán nunca debió haber
sido la construcción de una nación nunca
se supuso que se estuviera creando una
democracia unificada y centralizada
nuestro único interés nacional vital en
afganistán sigue siendo hoy lo que
siempre ha sido prevenir un ataque
terrorista en la patria estadounidense
y me parece completamente chocantes
de hecho lo más chocante fue cuando hubo
una explosión en el aeropuerto de kabul
y murieron unas 150 personas
y bailén sólo mencionó a los tres
estadounidenses que murieron
en realidad hubo un esfuerzo para causar
una construcción nacional en afganistán
hubo un esfuerzo para ayudar a las
mujeres para proteger a la gente para
traer de vuelta el desarrollo
pero en realidad el problema no fue que
la construcción nacional no funcionara
el problema fue que la construcción
nacional fue socavada por la guerra
contra el terror
desde el principio a los estadounidenses
estaban más preocupados por derrotar al
qaeda y derrotar a los talibanes y
derrotar al estado islámico que por
proteger a los afganos
y hacer de afganistán un lugar más
seguro para los afganos
y en realidad lo que no entendieron es
que esta lucha continua produjo una
reacción contraria
los talibanes estaban derrotados en 2001
la insurgencia no comenzó hasta 2006
y lo que es más en la lucha para
derrotar a los talibanes y al qaeda
mintieron con los antiguos muyahidines
un pueblo que había luchado contra los
soviéticos y que era inmensamente
corrupto
por lo que había mucha desconfianza en
el gobierno porque había mucha
corrupción y porque había muy poca
justicia
como estos tipos eran aliados en la
guerra contra el terrorismo se salieron
con la suya impunemente por lo que el
gobierno perdió legitimidad pero aún así
la vida estaba mejorando y el verdadero
problema fue que trump decidió negociar
con los talibanes e hizo un trato para
que eeuu se retirara dejándoles el país
a los talibanes y bailén se limitó a
seguir las políticas de trump
y usted utiliza el concepto de paz
híbrida para explicar lo que sucede en
determinados conflictos contemporáneos
que es la posibilidad
lo que pasa es que como una gran
maquinaria que es la pasó hoy en día
están tensos por presuponer que las
nuevas guerras son antiguas guerras por
lo que tratan de hacer acuerdos entre
las partes beligerantes
y por supuesto si las partes
beligerantes solo están interesadas en
la guerra para su propio beneficio no
están realmente interesadas en conversar
a menos que se puedan garantizar
posiciones efe
están interesadas y la violencia que
emprenden es contra los civiles en lugar
de la batalla en lugar del uno contra el
otro
pueden hacer un acuerdo para continuar
la violencia contra los civiles
de hecho como sabemos es terriblemente
difícil hacer un acuerdo de paz porque
las partes beligerantes no están
interesadas en la paz
así que hay que prometer les mucho como
se hizo en bosnia para llegar a la paz
entonces lo que realmente sucede cuando
se consigue un acuerdo como se hizo en
bosnia es que se congela la situación se
atrinchera a esas personas a las partes
beligerantes y es como si la guerra
fuera eterna
[Música]
y eso reduce la violencia para el
acuerdo de paz pero sin embargo las
partes beligerantes siguen con su
comportamiento depredador y siguen
violando los derechos humanos siguen
siendo extremadamente cortas
en the context mari de global en este
contexto la sociedad civil aparece como
un actor clave en la sociedad ya no se
puede entender limitada a la frontera de
los estados
la gente está conectada a lo largo de
todo el mundo
el word es real y casi una de las claves
para responder y traer soluciones a los
conflictos de esta era de conflictos de
serra
ay
yo creo que sí es decir en todos estos
conflictos se encuentran muchas personas
que podemos llamar sociedad civil que
realmente rechazan la condición social
de la guerra son los activistas de la
sociedad civil
de autor y normalmente el mundo exterior
piensa que son muy agradables el
sardinero pero no se dan cuenta de que
tienen que aliarse para crear una
alternativa
y creo que los vínculos transfronterizos
son increíblemente importantes para
ayudar a fortalecer la sociedad civil en
las zonas de conflicto
creo que la tragedia es que desde la
guerra contra el terrorismo estamos
sufriendo una especie de
renacionalización de la política
cuando empecé a escribir sobre la
sociedad civil global era muy optimista
de hecho elaboramos estos libros anuales
sobre la sociedad civil mundial y el
primero iba a publicarse el 17 de
septiembre de 2001 sense and one
y se vio interrumpido por los
acontecimientos del 11 de septiembre
pero no solo se interrumpió sino que se
interrumpió nuestra publicación
creo que todo el concepto de sociedad
civil global se había interrumpido claro
que seguimos viendo extinción rebelión
la clac smarter pero el tipo de
solidaridad con la gente común en
afganistán la solidaridad con la gente
común en síria existe
pero no llega al discurso global en el
mismo grado y eso me preocupa mucho
acerca del futuro
mary jane en general que enfoque de
seguridad humana prima en la actualidad
y como cree usted que debemos abordar la
seguridad humana
bueno estoy muy a favor de la seguridad
humana creo que tenemos que pasar de la
seguridad nacional a la seguridad humana
y la seguridad humana significa
anteponer los individuos la seguridad de
los individuos y las comunidades a la
seguridad de los estados nacionales
[Música]
y es justo lo contrario de lo que decía
bailén y en estas guerras en las que la
principal violencia se ejerce contra los
civiles intentar desarrollar un enfoque
de seguridad humana que significa
centrarse en la protección de las
personas más que en ganar contra el
enemigo
y significa tener una perspectiva global
es tremendamente importante américa
américa dor muchas gracias por su
presencia en la entrevista de france 24
y en nuestra audiencia como siempre le
invitamos a continuar informándose en el
resto de nuestra programación y también
por supuesto en pruebas 24 punto com
sigan con nosotros
[Música]